with with my apologies for uh being
tardy by five minutes I would like to uh
open the U capital budget overview
committee uh cap project overiew
committee project I'm I'm going off my
agenda the um and um with that I would
um you have copies of the minutes of May
26 six before
you move approval Mr
chairman I have a question on it a
suggestion nowhere on there do we list
you as the chair so either up in the the
with the members we put chair behind his
name or down in the minute we say chair
c more informative than people try to
thank you Senator gray um without
objection We Will We Will U amend the
minutes to represent uh listing the
chair at the top
makoni uh motion was
made um and
seconded um made by Boyd seconded
by okay lying Senator Lang oh Senator
Lang okay if you're in favor of that
motion you'll signify with correction uh
signified by saying I I if you're
opposed motion carries
unanimous
um Mr Shay would you
um Enlighten the board on we now do have
this new name change don't we for our
committee we we do um I could do that
after Environmental Services does their
presentation to the committee if you
would like or I can do it now but let's
let's do it okay so House Bill 384
passed the session uh last session in
that bill uh this committee's name was
changed from capital budget to Capital
project overview committee and part of
the discussion that was involved at that
time was that there is a number of
projects that are occurring outside the
capital budget process that are still
capital projects but they don't there
was concern that they didn't necessarily
have to come before this committee to be
updated or reviewed so the uh house
finance committee put an amendment in to
make that change um from budget to
projects um a little later on at the end
of the meeting well there's a
miscellaneous item which would kind of
set some parameters to help guide the
agencies on what is meant by a
project um but that that's a in a
nutshell what what occurred thank you
thank you Mr Shay for that and we'll
come back to that at the end I'd like to
move on to uh item number for
informational uh we'll start with
23015 Department of administrative
services so anyone here to discuss that
or
questions nothing okay uh Department of
Transportation
23016 annual status report of local
Federal and local uh airport
projects
thank you please introduce
yourselves morning Mr chairman members
of the committee Andre Brier Deputy
Commissioner NHD and I'm Carol n I'm the
senior Aviation planner at New Hampshire
do Bureau of Aeronautics thank
you so members of the committee uh uh in
accordance with chapter 90 laws of
2021 uh We've we've uh distributed uh
and attached the Department's annual
report uh for the period ending June
30th 2023 for review by uh the project
overview
committee um in fiscal year
um uh 20 uh 21 uh we passed uh federal
funds uh cares Chrissa and uh arpa uh
through to our airports to cover impacts
uh of uh the pandemic and the effects
those that uh pandemic had on those
airports uh largely um according to the
spreadsheets that we
distributed uh the first two categories
are expended and we are currently uh
just to summarize and not belabor um or
recount uh the spreadsheets that we did
did distribute we continue to expand uh
RP act funding uh and those are uh uh
mostly programmed and uh we're spending
our way through those but the first
first two categories are largely already
expended and distributed thank you any
questions thank you for your time
thanks um next item informational is
capap
2317 um which is a biannual report of
appropriated funds matching private
funds for the Coos County Rail and the
straford and Carroll County rail
improvements uh both Representatives had
spoken to me and said they had other
commitments and couldn't be here today
so um if there are questions that we
would like to pose to uh to their uh
spending then please let myself or Mr
Shay know and we could bring that up the
next
time
um item
23018 Department of Environmental
Services this has been the most
anticipated event of our day
so I'm we're honestly looking forward to
hearing this and if gentleman could come
forward and
uh thank you thank you Mr chair uh for
the record Bob Scott commissioner of the
Department of Environmental Services to
start uh I've asked uh commissioner
goule uh to sit sit with me thank you
for that uh so uh first of all I think
you all should have a handout if if you
don't we have extras here that we can
provide you so if anybody needs we can
do so uh I I just wanted to give some
opening remarks and I I'll have uh
assistant commissioner Mark Sor and our
head head of our land resource
management Bureau uh Phil trage uh are
going to give the the majority of the
presentation uh from the slides but I I
want to kind of state the obvious for
you all uh the e- permitting automation
uh of reporting and monitoring uh data
is really important uh for many reasons
I'm sure the the chair is a user of our
data uh and that's not unique uh we have
a lot of users of our data uh ranging
from the public just wants to understand
uh Environmental Quality around them to
uh practitioners that are so important
to our economy uh and and the key to
moving forward to that is we already
have for decades now we've we've kind of
clued together uh resources that are
available online uh that's really
long-term untenable we needed to to up
up the game on that uh and at the same
time and so that's why these funds are
so important to us uh and at the same
time obviously those decades worth of
products that we've been had been
producing uh we have people depending on
those and we need to Main main those so
it's it's akin to redesigning and
rebuilding a car while you're driving it
down the road is is what we're trying to
do uh we worked very closely with doit
uh as we should be uh in fact uh we did
a little bit of a course correction uh
with where we were going with this to
more better align in talking to Dennis
with the longterm where the state's
going to end up uh to make sure that we
don't have any missteps um and with that
again I just want to reiterate the the
importance
the obviously the at this point our our
the state the state uh our customers uh
expect this type of service and frankly
uh we have increasing demands on our
staff and this is the way to make them
more efficient so so this is something
we're fully bought on to uh and with
that uh I don't know if any comments uh
with uh commissioner
goule uh good morning Mr chair members
of the committee um I I have to agree
with everything so that's been said so
far and I want to elaborate a little bit
on you know commissioner Scott's course
correction comment um so um the history
of applications in the state has gone
along the same lines of of you know the
way priv private sector has done you
know in the old days everything was
written custom and and was maintained by
staff um today um the world is pretty
much bu buying software off the shelf
and they're also buying there's the the
the type the way you buy software has
changed so in the old days you'd buy
software you'd license it and then you'd
pay 15 to 20% maintenance per year and
um you wouldd own it for however long
and then you might switch it out after
you know eight years 10 years 20 years
however long today it's uh there's it's
the world has gone towards
subscription um from a from the
standpoint of the vendor ERS uh it's a
good thing for them and their
shareholders because they have this more
steady continuous um Revenue stream and
so they're more predictable as companies
for us it's good and bad um the the good
part is that we have a predictable cost
stream and that we're actually being
transparent about what it really costs
to operate uh because you know in the
old days You' have that huge cost of
implementing and then you'd be paying
your maintenance now it's kind of more
even and you're essentially probably at
over say a 10 or 12 year period at about
the same rate um you know the bad news
is it it makes it look like it's more
expensive right off the bat so that's
just a financial analysis one of the
things that I ask Environmental Services
to do particularly around um getting the
uh approval for the sweep money was to
kind of switch around from you know kind
of a focus on the back end of the
systems um with the anticip ation of
that being completed and then working to
the front end which is affects our
customers directly was go the flip that
completely around and focus
on getting impact positive impact for
our constituents on our system sooner
sooner than we would have otherwise
additionally do that with our standard
case management platform which is
Salesforce now for the state so we we
dipped our I I want to say about five
years ago we dipped our toe in the water
with Salesforce by doing a pilot with
the governor's citizen service office
they had an old uh it was the very first
implementation they had an old custom um
case management system that they were
using for um citizen service we
implemented Salesforce in an 8-week time
period for them so that was you know
compared to older implementations that
would have taken you know writing custom
software you know eight months later
you're done 12 months later you're done
uh that was extremely fast
implementation we've since implemented a
lot of uh a lot of Salesforce pretty
quickly and and that's really our intent
for Environmental Services is create a
machine we've already got a big part of
that machine created and it's moving
where we're taking uh and modernizing
citizen impact um stuff on the uh
Environmental Services um digital
government platform so so what you'll
see uh in the in the presentation today
is you know where we are on that um and
how you know in some ways how the um how
that shift and focus has impacted what
we're working
on thank
you so obviously we we' be happy to feel
questions but I think it may be if you
know depending on the committee's
desires it may be more instructive again
if I can bring assistant commissioner
samour and uh administrator uh tro up
they could walk through the the slides
and then maybe perhaps if it's all right
with the chair we could do questions at
the end sounds good I just while I have
while I have you here commissioner um I
had a I'm a practitioner I'm I'm on that
site all the time uh but we had a um
community in molten Boro that had a um a
community septic system uh that the town
didn't really know anything about it
there were no records the um the people
that are part of that system had very
little knowledge of it we had a customer
that wanted to um reintroduce their
waste again into it um and I just want
to just point out through the archives I
believe the the lady's name is Melinda
town uh did a tremendous job in a couple
days coming up with stacks of archived
material that no one even knew was out
there and it's a great benefit to that
that whole community the toll so I'm
very very excited about what's happening
with this and the digitizing and uh
thank you and I'm very appreciative that
we're going to have this presentation
well thank you for that we'll pass on
the kind words and as you mentioned uh
part of it part of our initiatives right
now our efforts are to digitize so that
only not only again does it make those
those uh data points available to our
staff to the industry but also to the
public who and as you mentioned the time
Town people can look online and find
this type of thing so that's that's a
great service thank
you okay we'll move on to uh the other
two
gentlemen morning everyone for the
record my name is Mark samor I'm the
assistant commissioner at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and with me is Phil trobridge
the uh manager of Our Land Resources
management program so I think everyone
has copies of the slide so um if we can
go to the uh first slide with content
the overview I'll um be just providing a
kind of overview of where we're going
and the two Commissioners did a great
job as always uh teeing it up um as I
had mentioned So currently we Dees has
um two Capital Appropriations that have
been provided by you all along with uh
an appropriation from the arpa funding
that the governor carved out called
sweep um for Our IT modernization
projects previously the department um
had been focusing on existing platforms
and the backend work was really where um
the majority of the work was happening
um we've refocused that the new focus is
on the new platform that um the
commissioner mentioned and working on
both the frontend and the backend work
another change in Focus has been um
going from originally we were going to
have a phased approach Department wide
working on elements needed for the
overall it modernization and e-
permiting effort um we've uh moved to
focusing on
lrm um the lrm programs for e permitting
to uh Implement in at least in the early
stages and we'll go over the reasons we
made that
choice um the other thing that is a
focus is um the uh data s uh our data uh
where we're storing our data uh instead
of having on premise it um servers we
are moving to moving to the cloud that
is both for security and financial
reasons it's cheaper and safer for place
to store your data so if you can move on
to the next slide we're going to I'm
going to provide an overview of the
projects we're working on that are all
part of the overall effort and then I'm
going to hand it over to Phil who's
going to go into a little more detail um
again the the reason Phil is here as the
lrm manager um he's really taking the
lead of in terms of the program side of
it um and he's the connection between
the program side and the IT staff so if
you look at the list eight projects each
one of those represents one of the areas
we're working on um as already mentioned
data warehouse um this dra project is
about improving data management through
it we anticipate increasing the speed of
our existing online queries andc
increasing Dees data
security the online programs for asbest
and asset management this project will
develop online fors for two important
programs the air Resources Division
asbest program and the Wastewater
engineering Bureau both projects will
increase staff productivity and save
time for our
customers the subsurface bureau's record
digitation it was just what we were just
talking about Mr chair um this project
will scan four million pages of paper
septic system and subdivision approvals
and make them available um to the staff
and public online uh this is one in
terms of immediate impact this is this
alone even if we weren't doing any of
the other changes this alone is going to
have an immediate benefit to both our
staff and our um our customers right now
these papers are stored in three
different locations we have a actual
storage bin archives and we have some
stored on premise and um finding them is
is is what leads to a lot of delays and
challenges so uh this project alone is
going to move the ball
forward subsurface Bureau designers and
installers electronic permitting process
this project will develop an online
process for renewing the LI for septic
system designers and installers in time
for the
2024 renewal
year the data check tool project uh the
natural heritage Bureau data check tool
was custom developed by New Hampshire
Dees for nhb so that applicant could
screen their projects for threatened and
endangered species this project will
move this tool to the new Statewide
Salesforce platform to make it easier
for nhb to maintain over the long
term now um there there's three
remaining projects below the last three
project listed represent where most of
the time and funding will be spent so
Phil's going to go over these in more
detail but I'll just give a quick brief
um overview um and then hand it over
again the migration the cloud servers
most re Hampshire uh DS data are stored
on servers maintained by doit staff this
project will move some data to servers
in the cloud which are scalable and
maintained by vendors again Phil's going
to cover a little more and the last two
boxes are related to our Salesforce e
filing most of our effort will be on
developing e filing for the land
resources management M programs using
the new Statewide platform of
Salesforce and that is really where the
heart of the effort over the next couple
of years is going to be so with that I'm
going to turn it over to Phil so he can
go into a little more detail for you
all great thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee uh so if you could turn
to the slide says a migration to Cloud
servers so this is one of the big
improvements we're seeking to make make
is to improve the resiliency of our web
services by moving away from owning on
premise Hardware to having contracts for
Cloud Server Services the cloud servers
provide better resiliency through
redundancy uh which lessens the risk of
outages they're also scalable to fit our
growing needs which is a great benefit
and I'd say most importantly the cloud
server cloud servers help us with our
productivity uh by freeing up staff time
from maintaining on premise Hardware and
allowing them to work on our priorities
for
development there's always a lot to
learn whenever you do any kind of
transition for technology so we're
starting with the servers that uh
provide the information for my program
first and hoping to learn from that as
we transition the rest of the
department so on to the the next slide
regarding the Statewide permit
portal this is our other big effort and
arguably this is the biggest effort uh
for the next few years it's putting all
the permits permit applications online
using the Statewide Salesforce platform
the image on this slide just shows the
the homepage of the permit platform so
you can see you know what it's going to
look like as as things go
online we're working with do in
Partnership to develop online forms for
this
portal and we've chosen to work with the
land resources program my program
because that's where the majority of our
customer interaction is uh we can we
have 118 total forms uh if for and that
represents you know four different large
permitting
programs putting these per forms online
first is going to have the greatest
impact for our
customers we've been uh in these last
few months we've been working with doit
and Salesforce on this project and
during the time we've been setting up
the platform for the whole state uh and
working on things like online payment
online mapping and E signatures and
we've also done some pilot tests with a
few of our forms to get to know the the
platform and get to know the team at
Salesforce and
doit you could move to the next slide
regarding eiling project
schedule this slide shows our plan for
rolling out the different permit
applications on the portal as well as
some of the other projects that that
Mark mentioned such as the digitization
project
it's an aggressive schedule uh going out
through 2025 but we believe it is
achievable we have staffed up to have
three project managers to organize our
data and to be the interface between the
subject matter experts on on the inside
at Dees and the developers at
Salesforce and then we've also required
for our contractors at Salesforce and
their and their subcontractors that they
have scalable capacity to fit our needs
so we we'll be able to match up the
information we provide with their
ability to produce so we can work at a
fast
Cadence and so with these uh with these
uh the situation we feel like we can
make rapid progress over the next two
years on the next
slide uh we show at least some of the
expected benefits of these it
Investments and I'll just take a minute
to describe the graph the the the right
Axis and the blue line show the number
of online forms uh that are going to be
available from the department and you
can see that starting in 2023 uh we
forecast doubling that that amount by
2026 the left axis and the bars on the
graph show the number of applications
that we expect to be submitted through
these online forms and we're starting
from a little bit higher Baseline here
because we have a one large eer program
already for the subsurface systems
Bureau that handles 6,000 applications a
year uh but even with that higher
Baseline we expect to increase the
online submittal by 60% over that same
time overall by the time we get to 2026
we plan to have 75% of all the land
resource permits to be done in
online and we and I should say that
we've prioritized our the ones that
we're doing first to be the ones that
have the greatest uh demand
the ultimate benefit to the customers
will be the ability to apply for most
Dees online permits or most permits
online without needing a printer a stamp
or a
check and for our Dees staff the
improvements will make it easier to
share the information between staff as
we have people working in different
offices uh and share it digitally uh
it'll reduce our need for paper
storage and it will speed up our
fulfillment of right to no
requests
you turn to um second to last slide on
current
status the table on this slide shows how
much of the existing Appropriations have
either been encumbered or spent which is
the second column uh or scoped and
assigned to a project which is the third
column and then the the the column on
the far right is the sum of those
two for the sweep and fy22 23 Capital
Appropriations These funds are mostly
accounted
for uh for FY 24 and 25
appropriation the availability of the
sweeps money which as you know must be
spent by
2026 has slowed our use of these funds
and we also just received them uh two
months ago and our priority has been uh
spending down the sweeps and the the
prior appropriation
first so and one thing I want to mention
though is that even though we've not
encumbered or assigned all of the
capital funds we expect to need these
full Appropriations and there's a couple
of reasons for that um the first is that
our initial approach for these online
forms has been to keep it very simple to
get the forms online as quickly as
possible and that's you know you know a
software development strategy um but we
know that there's going to be a need for
a phase two to add more features that
customers are going to want and we have
not scoped or budgeted that because we
don't know what those are and we're
going to learn those through engagement
with our with our customers and find out
what it is they want so we don't
overbuild and we focus on what you know
satisfies their
needs uh similarly uh we have not uh
fully scoped the replacement of the
existing e pering program for the
subsurface systems Bureau this was a is
it was a popular is a popular program it
was custombuilt in 2015 it handles uh
6,00
applications already but we need to move
it from this custom built platform to
the Salesforce platform for it's uh to
be stable and also to be maintainable in
the long run uh this is going to be a
big project and we expect it to be uh uh
costly and that's why you know we expect
that to be um it's it we expect to use
all the incumbrances or all the
appropriation and uh before I leave this
side let me address a likely question
you may have which is you know why are
there funds um from the FY 2425
appropriation assigned to a project when
there's still unassigned funds for 22 23
uh and the reason for that is that the
2425 appropriation had a few specific
projects listed with it that were fully
scoped already and ready to go and we've
got them moving
quickly Mark I'll turn it back to you to
summarize yeah thank thanks Phil um a
couple points I want to overwatching
thoughts I want to leave you with before
we move into questions um number one we
hope that um the information we provided
demonstrates that we are prioritizing
our customer needs and leveraging doit
Statewide
assets and
resources um when I also uh you
know feel accurately in um and
effectively outlined why we are
concentrating on lrm I do want the folks
to know here though that doesn't mean um
we aren't uh we're leaving out the rest
of the department um during this time um
number one overall from an IT
perspective our three priorities of DS
right now are is the lrm permitting
efforts and the IT modernizations
associated with it but our number two
priority is maintenance of the Legacy
program programs throughout the rest of
the department those um uh those
platforms will continue um to get the um
attention they need so the rest of our
department continues um to meet the
needs of our
constituents and the third priority is
the new development of some non lrm we
have received some additional fundings
we provided some funding to both air and
um uh waste divisions um that we were
working on so we're possible some new
development is happening in the rest of
the department um it also should be
noted that the work being done right now
will benefit those other um programs
once we move to those it
modernization um as we learn more and we
get better at adapting Salesforce as a
platform um improving our uh data
storage um and all the efforts that are
associated with the
modernization um both on the front end
and the back end um all the lessons will
pay dividends when we go to um
increasing e permitting and our forms
online um when we get to the other
programs so uh in closing we are
focusing on the project that will make
online forms available as quickly as
possible and focusing on on lrm simp
they represent the majority of New
Hampshire de's permitting efforts um but
we are ensuring along the way that our
customers uh immediate needs are met and
that these benef uh these lessons and
efforts will benefit all of Dees um down
the line with that I think we're ready
for your questions certainly questions
for the
gentlemen oh I'm sorry yes
representative thank you and thank you
for taking my question so can you speak
to the issues related to privacy and
data sec As you move from a platform
from your own platform which is totally
under your control into the outer world
where many more people have access to
your
system yeah we're going to bring up the
real it expert for that one thank
you thanks that's a great question and
it's one you should be asking um so the
um one of the things that's happened in
in the IT world is that um particularly
for state and local governments is that
you know our requirements for security
and privacy are are um not only just
important but in in many ways they
they're uh required to be compliant with
our federal funding streams so all of
the major players in the cloud space
have created what they call a government
Cloud so you have your commercial Cloud
so if I was working for say a software
company or something and I was running a
cloud-based platform like Salesforce I
would probably buy the commercial Cloud
because it's security strong um and I
can manage it but I don't have those
Federal compliance
requirements uh they all have a
government Cloud that steps up their
compliance and their diligence as it
relates to data privacy and data
security so that um we actually pay a a
premium for that service um but it's
something we would have to do internally
anyway we get audited by um by our
federal Partners all the time um and of
course they audit us um on different
standards I wish the the federal
government would pick a standard and and
and evaluate us on that but but that's
not the case today um so we are very
good at being audited and so it's really
really helpful to have a platform that
is uh fedramp compliant now what fedramp
means is that there's a third party
entity that's evaluated that vendor and
and and not only evaluated them one time
but there's regular compliance checks to
make sure that they're maintaining their
their um security and privacy um
diligence uh there's also another H and
and to be fed ramp compliant you
actually have to do business with the
federal government not all players out
there do business with the federal
government so uh there's also a state
ramp compliancy and what that is is it's
it's the same amount of discipline but
it strikes away that Reliance on or the
requirement that a federal relationship
be there so we look for those
compliances for a smaller vendor who's
in the space who might not um be able to
manage that type of um compliancy we
have a pretty rigorous um process inside
our procurement uh so in in we evaluate
what our our vendors are doing with
respect to security and privacy uh as
part of the procurement process it's a
lot easier to do if there State ramp or
fed ramp compl client but if they're not
then you know we have that extra level
of work that we have to do to um to make
sure that we're being careful with
citizen data uh the other thing we do is
particularly on large new system
implementations and we've done this uh
already once with Salesforce we did it
as we were getting ready to go live with
our vaccination system Vinnie um we
actually did a third-party audit said
all right you know it's fed Ram
compliant should be very secure but did
we make any mistakes implementing it so
it's a regular thing that we do uh where
we'll do a thirdparty assessment of how
we've implemented to make sure that we
didn't make any configuration mistakes
that leave data doors
open hope that answers the question it's
a long answer but there's a lot of work
being done our our enemies are targeting
us
continuously thank you very much thank
you any further
questions um I want to um I want to
thank you uh folks for all coming in
today and that presentation we look
forward to uh as this progresses forward
um Chris um can maybe you've already
done this could you make this a PDF and
share it with all of the public works if
you could please we can do that it's
it's currently on the website on our
website and we'll forward links to the
public works okay I I would appreciate
that uh for your gentlemen I guess I
just have one question and the God
forbid this were to happen and all you
were here with us today is Rainey in
charge of the department now if you guys
are all
gone he actually he's at Sil farm so uh
he's ready to go over there so yes well
we want to thank you for the
appropriation so we couldn't be doing
any of these without the investment
being made by the legislature so thank
you very much thank you all right the um
if if I could hold you Mr Sor I have a
question for you about our other
commission we're on Sure hold you after
and um thank thank you for that and
we'll move on to uh Mr Shay so so the
last item on your agenda today is under
miscellaneous it's
23019 um so as I mentioned at the start
of the committee the project n uh the
committee name had changed from capital
budget to capital
projects and prior to that in RSA 17j
the department of administrative
Services is uh required to do a
quarterly report on all capital budget
projects and that's what's been included
that's what you had on um today's packet
would be 23- 015 so that's the quarterly
report that you receive typically that
has been just what's been included in
the capital budget those new items from
the current capital budget and anything
that's been carried forward from
previous Capital budgets by changing the
name to capital projects there was a
question as to what did that mean what
needs to be included in the court of the
report
so the item under um tab five 23019 is
an effort to um provide some guidance to
administrative services on what should
be included in the court of the report
the first number one is to continue to
include any Capital uh budget items that
you've approved through House Bill 25
the second would be to include any
capital projects with an appropriation
of a million dollars or
more the third would be to include um
any Capital project that the oplc funds
through its dedicated fund so
legislation this year was adopted to
allow that group to use their dedicated
fund for capital projects and you'll see
on the bottom of the page I referenced
the RSA there and then the last point
was to um include any other projects
that committee members might bring up
that they believe should be tracked by
this
group so it I had reached out to the
chair as well as representative eel who
was involved with some of this um some
of these changes during the house
finance phase um to see if this was kind
of getting to the place where they
thought they should be with this and uh
so this is why you have this Draft
before you and if the committee agrees
to it if you could give us an
affirmative vote to say that this is the
policy you want to be used we'll share
it with the state agencies so they know
what to have included qu questions first
for uh Mr Shay about
this um is yes please Senator grg uh is
that going to get me a
report on how fishing game is doing on
their project for computers is that
their project for which project the
updating the computer system to take
online
registrations it should it should it
should be included in this packet uh the
the coure of the report if they have
capital budget and it's considered a
capital project that that's got over a
million
dollars further
yes
repr um well thank you very much Mr
chair uh as the chair and representative
clud you know I was a long-term member
of Public Works and highways and then
when IED long well I don't know about
esteemed but um so um it had given I
would say a lot of us a little bit of
heartburn when there were capital
projects that weren't sort of going
through the regular capital budget uh
review process because they were going
through through Finance because they
were coming through um that source of
funding as opposed to a capital budget
so um in the discussion of the
construction of the legislative parking
garage there was another situation that
was arising that involved you know
legislative oversight and so in the
process of that discussion uh we saw or
I in particular saw an opportunity to um
bring capital projects that weren't
otherwise in the capital budget uh
process into some sort of review process
that I felt and and you know everybody
supported it uh deserved an equal amount
of oversight and they weren't getting it
just because they were in coming through
um the regular operating budget so
that's where uh that was the Genesis of
all of that and that's how we Chang the
name uh to Capital project overview view
but then Chris was kind enough to point
out that that sort of left this never
Neverland um of what how many of
projects that were being paid for with
capital funds should be um reviewed by
the group and representative makoni and
I chatted about it and we felt like a
million dollars was a good um good level
so at some point if you want a motion to
approve this I I um I I would accept a
motion motion motion has been
made um and seconded
by rep
bble okay um further
discussion seeing none if you're in
favor of the motion which is the
guidelines outlined under
23019 um signified by saying I I any
opposed thank you all for that motion
carries
unanimous the I believe the last item
and last item is our next meeting and uh
looks like it'll be December
15th and the time of this meeting would
be nine o'clock nine
o'clock if that is an issue for the
members uh please let Chris or myself
know about
that yes um an agenda item for that
meeting I would like to see fishing game
come in um there was several legislators
that expressed disappointment in their
progress on their computer upgrades and
there is a special provision in House
Bill 2 uh that talks to what they are
supposed to be doing so uh since it
would be a project I would like to see
them on the agenda to come in and EXP
explain to us what their plan of action
and Milestones are and how they have uh
uh progressed on those since the one
that was presented to us at the time of
the budget thank you Senator without
objection one moment M question so these
meetings are generally sounds like you
guys have them on the third Friday of
the month I think Senator gray might
have the same concern I have that's also
I believe when fiscal generally meets at
10:00 if I have that correct will the
9:00 at 10:00 be
done the anticipation is that um this
meeting would be done in time for fiscal
um this meeting you just had and the
meeting that's scheduled in October for
fiscal are set for Thursday so I don't
know if that's going to go back to
Fridays or not or but you're absolutely
correct representative it has been
talked about as the third Friday
typically at 10 o'clock sometimes in the
afternoon but um usually Capital project
overview committee goes rather quickly
and that's why we've asked to have it
scheduled at 9 9:30 the long range
committee would be um scheduled to
participate or to start sorry thanks
okay thank you representative so without
objection we'll ask fishing game for
Senator gray and for my own and I'm sure
everyone else have OCC to have them come
forward yeah we'll have them included on
the agenda we'll let them know the
request has been made okay so uh with
that we'll accept a motion to adjourn
until so move by the senator seconded by
represent clude here uh if you're if
you're in favor of the motion um signify
by saying I I any oppos we are
adjourned I didn't look left so we
didn't
that